君たち石川切って知ってる感想あの僕は富山県出身なんですけど
web 系の隣に石川気になるんですその隣にある石川県むつら好きなんですよ
今日はねその石川県のねちょっと夢かねえ石川県で金沢だ
金津あの有名なチゲや石川の中に彼女はがあるんですよ
田中
マザーのね有名なカレーの紹介しようと思いますこちらのゴーゴーカレーです
知らないいや吸ってんのコレ有名かわかんないっ
b
あのて山健民だがちょっとわかると思うよ
なんかで謎ねこの金沢に退社憧れがあってなんかね
無駄に高ねなんか買い物に行きたくなったら無駄に公花沢に行きたいって言うねこうだ
かってんなた謎にせずらコザでがあるんですねやまけんよね
じゃ早速作っていきましょう5分カレーです shy shy 来いって言ってる
ソイソイソイもう
ええええええ
alors
r r r あーあーさー
ani
なんか尺書いてあったぞなんか本当はご飯にキャベツとカツを乗せてカレーをかけて
完成なんですけどちょっとは僕は勝つとかないんで結構ね
黒目の結構濃いめのカレーの目標明日たり型ではなくかついる使ったなぁ雑草いただき
ます今日の昼御飯です
うんあの味お店で食ったあると同じです
ちょっと要なんですよ辛いと食べれないんですけどもこれぐらいなぁ
あんまりしてくれろ
まあ無理してくれるだろうって感じですね
フェア今やっぱ特徴的なのアズルこいです
すごい濃い汗なんですけどや見つけないというかこーぽ所々崩れるというかちょっと
病みつきになるタイプの味です
ちょっと美容室ちょっとやばいちょっと美容室に行かれてたんですけどちょっといっ
やばいちょっと遅れそうじゃバイ
はカレーのカレーを食べ放題じゃんね
せませ千葉さんのちょっとくれそうなんですけどそれでも空いている時間
で大丈夫です
じゃあさんじゃなんでー
はい
どうぞ
ごめんのすいませんはい売れします
me